thanks very much for everyone who's here
it's a very good gathering and I think
it's really begun very well with the the
Alpha wash of crown that was what a
great thing to show you the first panel
of today is about the board since the
theme of today is the ascent rally of
the board to governance and how the
milstein Center is going to focus on
that I want to make by way of sort of a
setup three specific points first is
that the activism we see is really
reflective of the triumph of the
Delaware model that puts the board at
the center of governance so I think
Delaware really should celebrate the
rise of the activism of the day and
protect it because it puts the board not
the hostile takeover but the board at
the center of the governance drama and
reasserts the centrality of the election
the proxy battle as the main vehicle for
board accountability the second claim is
that what the new form of the activism
shows us is that the board needs to
evolve and that that's a good thing the
current model of the board which
consists really of outside directors who
are part-timers in their role who
monitor quote unquote but do not manage
that's an invention of legal academics
writing in the 1970s they're good things
they're strong they're strong things
they're weak weak things about the model
the point is it was and is an experiment
in design it's not from Sinai and I
think what the present wave shows us is
that a rethink is in what is in order
the third claim is that the
short-term the short-termism the long
term term ism debate is it's a symptom
it's not a cause it's it it shows us
that for the large public firm we do not
have a monitoring device that can
credibly claim that management strategy
is indeed the wisest course of action
for the creation of shareholder value
over the long term management's are
prone to long-term ism as well as
short-termism the present government set
up is often unable to provide credible
reassurance to the owners of the
institutional investors to distinguish
the two and so the right response is not
to bemoan this change but rather
governance innovation which brings us
back to the board as well as
appreciation that the governance needs
of the firm will vary in the cross
section so that we should expect
differences across firms and differences
over time so we need to think about how
to avoid the lock-in of a governance
structure that might be exactly the
right one for this moment but not a good
at ation for a later moment so I want to
come back to point to which is the
nature of the monitoring board and the
limitations of it so the issue with the
monitoring board is that the directors
the new directors were outsiders from an
information point of view how could they
monitor the management team without deep
knowledge of the firm and the business
environment in which it's at the stock
market actually provided the answer
through the production of informative
stock prices that would impound the
available information about the firm as
well as its competitors aided by an
increasingly full and rich sec
disclosure regime
and so the stock price is based on that
could overcome significantly overcome
the information gap that the directors
had because they provided a basis for a
year against year performance comparison
and comparison against firms in the same
business and plus you you tie a comp
compensation to stock prices and and
this was the way we would monitor the
managerial team but notice of course the
stock prices aren't limited not only the
information about the firm's future
direction which might not be already
revealed because after all it would
disclose that to competitors but also
stock markets are not perfect you might
say but but still the monitoring model
we had given the shareholders of the
time who were dispersed was a
significant improvement over the inside
monitoring model or lack of monitoring
model that that we had before but think
about 2015 and how the ownership
patterns have changed the fact that we
can in a really credible way get get the
owners of many large firms around a
table not much bigger than the ones
you're sitting at and think about how
that governance model is not well suited
so a governance structure a governance
model that's premise on thinly informed
directors because that's what we have
these firms expose to the hedge fund
attack think about it from the point of
view of the institutional owners
considering the claim the hedge fund
claim ex-ante the hedge fund should be
unbiased it makes the touhou of
investment and starts the campaign only
if it believes the firm is mismanaged
either in the financial or Dziedzic
sense why is that because the hedge fund
in effect is an asset manager whose
business
depends upon repeated success over time
it earns returns from appreciation and
stock ownership its ability to to
credibly deliver positive returns a is
important to generating funds from from
the outside investors in the next period
and B to sustaining credibility with the
institutional investors who support that
it needs for any campaign that it offers
to be successful so so in a sense it's
it's effort is to gain a credibility
with the institutional owners that its
plans will be will bring strategic
improvement in in in the firm alright so
their unbiased in the sense and I'm
describing the pitch on the other hand
from that the institutional investors
see is from management which is by
definition biased and so how how are the
new owners supposed to resolve the
dispute because after all they probably
start off by favoring the management
team because even in an indexed
environment you're looking to the
activists the activists managers in the
group for guidance as to how to vote the
shares and presumably they invest it in
the farm because they believe in the
management team so they start off
believing that management is right
nevertheless the hedge fund comes comes
with a thick deck of slides with a
reasonable business cases how to improve
value who is the institutional owner
supposed to look to under the present
board model the institutional investor
cannot look to the thinly informed
director to help adjudicate this dispute
that's the point the directors don't
have the clout because they aren't put
there to know enough to be able to say
we've really thought about it and
actually the management team the
strategy that the board that the current
board has or the current farm has is the
better stress
energy so on this few this leads to a
new role for the board credibly verify
that management strategy is best for the
firm boards need directors with that
credibility we're not surprised by
what's in the hedge fund slide deck but
who indeed no more than what's in it it
means directors tasked in a different
way we need directors who will be
thickly informed who have a different
sense of expectation is about their role
on the board of directors so so again I
want to come back to the notion that
what we have is a diagnosis in search of
a solution the the same institutional
investors who supposedly vote for the
short term also invest in VC firms in PE
firms in blind polls in effect which is
the very definition of long-term
investing why do they do it because they
believe in the governance model and
that's the point the evidence that we
now have before us is not that the hedge
funds are good or bad it's that there's
a diagnostic issue that they bring to
bear which is that the governance model
of a large public firm needs renovation
we need a high-powered board I think is
part of the solution to that and that's
the intro for the next pound